foreign
night from London the new kings first
addressed to the nation a son Mourns his
mother we owe her the most heartfelt
debt any family could owe to their
mother and sets the course for his own
reign as hundreds greet him at
Buckingham Palace operation London
Bridge the protocol now that the queen
has died plus what happens to the
monarchy now I think it's becoming more
of the 21st century what difference the
transition to King Charles might make
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from London
[Music]
it's told at Westminster Abbey and at
hundreds of churches across the country
one Bell each minute for an hour in
honor of Queen Elizabeth II
good evening and thanks for joining us
it was here at Westminster Abbey just
behind me that the late Queen swore her
coronation oath and set the course for a
lifetime of devoted service it's where
she was married and where her funeral
will take place the country is in the
midst of mourning and great transition
there is a new king and thousands of
people crowded the gates of Buckingham
Palace today to greet King Charles III
less than 24 hours after the death of
his mother it was an emotional moment at
one point the crowd singing God saved
the king it marks both an ending and a
new beginning
later Charles gave his first address as
king
I know that her death brings great
sadness to so many of you
and I share that sense of loss beyond
measure with you all
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
I too now solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time God grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
King Charles is his mother's son but
he's his own man and he will have to
Define his own version of the monarchy
it is already undergoing change Prince
William and his wife Kate were given new
roles today as the Duke and Duchess of
Cornwall titles previously held by
Charles and his wife Camilla they'll
also be both The Prince and Princess of
Wales our Europe bureau chief crystal
gemancing is with me crystal Donna
following in his mother's footsteps King
Charles III pledged a life of devotion
and service in his first televised
address it is clear that he is mourning
the loss of his mother but as Monarch it
is his duty to help people here in the
UK in Canada and around the world get
through the Monumental loss of their
Queen
from the banks of the Thames to the
stone walls of Edinburgh Castle
96 rounds fired for a life of
service-lived and pledged she showed the
world
not just how to Reign Over a people she
showed the world how to give
how to love
and how to serve her late Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II was one of the greatest
leaders the world has ever known
she was the rock on which modern Britain
was built but while she understood the
inescapital nature of Duty which
sometimes must have weighed Upon A
heavily she also delighted in carrying
it out the weight of the crown now rests
on King Charles a man who started the
week as the Prince of Wales it will no
longer be possible for me to give so
much of my time and energies to the
Charities at issues for which I care so
deeply
but I know this important work Will Go
On In The Trusted hands of others
Charles championed many causes the
environment was one that he advocated
for tirelessly and one his son the heir
to the throne has taken up in recent
years with Catherine beside him our new
Prince and Princess of Wales will I know
continue to inspire and Lead our
national conversations
helping to bring the marginal to the
center ground where vital help can be
given
I want also to express my love for Harry
and Megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas one expression of love and
unity to another 2 000 members of the
public attended a service at St Paul's
Cathedral in memory of the queen and in
honor of the king
[Music]
foreign
service I renew to you all today
a new pledge of service and devotion and
a new national anthem here in the UK one
we will hear many more times likely
tomorrow when the session Council
formally proclaims King Charles Donna
Crystal gemancing thanks this period of
national mourning means major cultural
political and sporting events have been
postponed in this country in the coming
days the Queen's body will be moved from
Balmoral to Buckingham Palace before
four days of lying in state at
Westminster Hall the date of her funeral
at Westminster Abbey behind me hasn't
been announced but it's expected to be
either Saturday or Monday it's clear
people want to pay their respects to the
late Queen and to the new King Redmond
Shannon is outside Buckingham Palace
tonight Redmond
hello Donna well what a day it has been
here earlier today the new King King
Charles III and the queen consort
Camilla arrived here at the gates of
Buckingham Palace hundreds of people
were here to wish them well many of them
got more than just a good wish they got
to shake hands with the new monarch he
went along the line for quite a long
period to speak to people one woman even
kissed his hand some people you could
see got visibly emotional during this
historic day and some people broke out
into God Save the King when he was there
thereafter we saw the brand new king and
queen take a look at the flowers that
side Buckingham Palace and then side by
side made their way through the front
Gates of Buckingham Palace
on the first full day of the new era of
Charles III this was the place so many
people felt they just had to be among
them three generations of the dando
family mourning what they describe as a
personal loss if anybody dies in our
family then we always like single rose
when they're coffin we can't do that so
we come to lay at the palace Gates she's
been our backbone really of the country
and um
we just thought we'd come up and enter
our best the Queens played a huge part
in our lives particularly my parents
have always been huge royalists so we've
been brought up to feel the same so yes
it's um it's a big loss for us she's
always been there visitors from across
the UK and all walks of life bringing
offerings from the heart these flowers
are a Queen Elizabeth Rose and I grew
them in my garden and I picked some and
I wanted to bring them up here Rosa
Queen Elizabeth grown in my garden from
Raynham in Kent The Garden of England a
beautiful rose for a beautiful woman Our
Queen we met Helena who told us she'd
escape the war in Ukraine this spring
for safety here I know a lot about Queen
because for me she a great woman
welcoming prime minister Justin Trudeau
in Windsor in March the Queen's subtle
choice of blue and yellow flowers
carried larger meaning for Helena I
think she supported ukrainians yeah we
feel it I think every day every
ukrainians feel it that britons are
supported ukrainians
Donna just as important as the things
that have been happening of course over
the last few days and coming days are
the things that are not happening the
significance of that many cultural and
sporting events have been postponed or
canceled we've had Music Awards and
music concert canceled stores have
closed today London Zoo of which the
queen is a patron closed today and over
the weekend there will be no Premier
League games you certainly know it is a
big deal in this country when the Brits
cancel their soccer games Donna
that's for sure Redmond Shannon outside
Buckingham Palace thanks the code name
for the Queen's funeral plans is
Operation London Bridge and it sets out
strict protocols to be followed both in
the UK and in commonwealth countries
including Canada Eric Sorensen explains
by the time members of the royal family
flew to Scotland and Balmoral Castle a
meticulous operation had been touched
off the queen is under medical
supervision the BBC's most senior
journalists came on the air dressed in
black even reporters in the field fully
expecting what was to come reporting the
death of her majesty the queen Clockwork
protocols that had been rehearsed for
years are now underway the Queen's body
is to remain in Scotland till Tuesday
then will be brought by Royal train to
London slowly so thousands can pay
homage along the way the queen will lie
and state at Westminster Hall
and in the same August setting where her
coronation took place at Westminster
Abbey the Queen's funeral will happen
almost 70 years later that will be an
amazing amount of Pomp and ceremony and
ritual that has to be followed towards
Von Queen Elizabeth
it is momentous in almost every country
in the world
the UK must now prepare to receive
scores of world leaders and with
unprecedented Security in Canada long
planned tributes are now also in motion
the beginning of a 10-day period of
mourning the statements by the Prime
Minister and the governor general flags
at half-mast the book of condolences for
the public in 10 days a national
ceremony is being planned starting with
the memorial parade including armed
forces in the RCMP a gun salute as in
London one round for each year of the
Queen's life an aerial fly pass over
Parliament Hill and a national
commemorative ceremony at ottawa's
Christ Church Cathedral with dignitary
Aries on the same day as the funeral at
Westminster
here and across the Commonwealth
gestures of public support ensure
continuity for the crown as much as for
the new king himself The Queen Is Dead
long live the king and and that kind of
sums it up that there's no interruption
the function continues unimpeded with
the beginning the transition to a new
reign
the transition will be a long one
official ceremonies notwithstanding it
will take time to adjust to life without
Queen Elizabeth Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
he spent his whole life waiting for this
moment coming up the significance of
Charles being in charge we're back from
London in a moment
[Music]
the Queen's death is a lot to process
for some people it marks a huge change
for the royal family and the world with
me now is Margaret McMillan she's a
Canadian historian and Emeritus
professor of history at Oxford
University Margaret this moment we're in
feels like a big transition I've heard
some people say it adds to the
uncertainty in the world but does the
death of a monarch really mean as much
today as it did in the past
think it does perhaps for different
reasons I think there was probably more
reverence for the Monarch or the person
of the Monarch in the past but I think
we still see the monarchy as something
which adds a sort of stability it shows
a sort of continuity it is an
institution the particularly the British
Monarchy I think which is above
divisions of society so it represents
society as a whole and I think we still
value it for that reason we perhaps
aren't as reverential as we once were I
mean when I was a child we had to stand
up whenever the national anthem was
played and in those days it was the
British national anthem not the Canadian
national anthem and that some of that's
gone but I think we still value the
monarchy for its symbolism and its
importance as this thing that is above
the divisions in society and of course
she was Queen longer than most people
were alive have been alive what do you
think the impact on Canada will be does
the transition to King Charles make a
difference
it will make a difference because he is
a different sort of person but he spent
a lot of time in Canada he comes here a
lot he's come with his wife his some of
his children went to school here and so
he has a number of links with this
country and I don't get any sense that
there's a feeling in Canada that we need
to get rid of the monarchy most people
see it as rather a nice symbol that
Canada is somehow different from the
United States and I think that's
important to us you know you said that
we're less reverential now of the
monarchy than in the past but do you
think it will be the same now that Queen
Elizabeth is dead
it will stay the same I think in some
Essentials but I think it's already
clear that King Charles III as he now is
and the air to the throne Prince William
is now the Prince of Wales will have
different views on what the monarchy
should be like and they've already been
more open in the way they live Prince
William is involved in a number of
Institutions for young people a number
of causes for young people he and his
wife Catherine have a very different
style from the queen and Prince Philip
and so the monarchy is adapting and
changing I think it's becoming more of
the 21st century as it adapted and
changed in the past
all right Margaret McMillan thanks so
much for joining us tonight
thank you it was a pleasure to talk to
you
this is Pond Inlet on Northern Baffin
Island in Nunavut even there the flag
flies at half mast to Mark the Queen's
death
we're back from London in a moment
Elton John like the rest of us grew up
with the queen and he liked the queen
has not slowed down at age 75 he is
still on tour and last night in Toronto
he paid tribute to the queen
and she led the country through some of
our greatest and darkest moments with
Grace decency and a genuine caring
warmth I'm you know 75 she's been with
me all my life and I feel very sad that
she won't be there with me anymore but
I'm glad she's at peace and I'm glad
she's at rest and she deserves it she's
worked bloody hard
Elton John then saying don't let this so
down on me saying we celebrate her life
tonight with music back in 1988 he was
knighted by the queen and he performed
at many Royal events including the
funeral of Diana Princess of Wales in
1997. the last public message posted by
the queen came on Wednesday words of
condolence for the victims of the mass
stabbing in Saskatchewan and their
families
the queen writing I would like to extend
my condolences to those who have lost
loved ones in the attacks in
Saskatchewan she said her thoughts and
prayers were with those recovering from
injuries and grieving such horrific
losses she said I'm mourned with all
Canadians at this tragic time
and now we're hearing more from grieving
residents of the James Smith cremation
in Saskatchewan Brian Burns lost his son
in Sunday's attack and his wife Bonnie
who he calls his Rock he says he needs
to stay strong for the rest of his
family
good bury your son and your wife at the
same time it's
tough but I'm trying to be brave
strong for my boys because
I'm there for them
try to be there for them strong
Brian Burns is calling for an inquest
into why the main suspect miles
Sanderson who died after being taken
into custody on Wednesday was released
from jail in February the parole board
of Canada confirms it will conduct a
joint investigation into that 10 people
were killed 18 others injured the second
suspect Damian Sanderson was found dead
on Monday the First Nations leaders are
praising the police efforts but do
question if a local Force could make a
difference in preventing future
tragedies
signs tonight A String of interest rate
hikes are starting to cool the Canadian
economy the unemployment rate Rose to
5.4 percent in August up from a record
low of 4.9 percent in July the economy
lost 40 000 jobs last month mostly in
education and construction marking the
third consecutive month of job losses
Health Canada has approved Pfizer's
covid-19 vaccine for children aged six
months to four years it is the second
vaccine approved for that age group
health Canada gave the green light to
moderna's shot in July there are three
weeks between the first and second doses
eight weeks between the second and third
Health Canada says it approved the
Pfizer biotech vaccine after what it
calls a thorough and independent
scientific review and says the benefits
outweigh the potential risks for kids
flags are also flying at half mast
all over the Commonwealth this is the
Canadian warship hmcs Margaret Brook
deployed in the Arctic
we're back from London in a moment
welcome back to London the queen met a
multitude of people over her 70-year
Reign and we're hearing lots of funny
and touching memories from those people
she traveled to Canada more than any
other country Mike drolet looks back at
some of the memorable moments from her
many trips there and here's from
Canadians who were left with a lasting
impression of the late monarch
There are rules when you meet a monarch
no matter the event or occasion
Canadians are planning to meet Queen
Elizabeth all should have received an
education on proper etiquette
so bewildered was NHL player Mike Ricci
as the queen was set to drop the
ceremonial Puck at a 2002 game in
Vancouver he did his best to class
things up tucking his long hair into his
sweater putting in his fake teeth and
then kept mostly quiet
all across Canada the Queen's passing is
being honored in traditional ways bells
ringing in Banff flowers around Queen's
Park and Toronto books of condolence for
people to sign in Edmonton Ottawa and
other cities but those who had the
privilege of meeting or say the same
thing all the formality and nervousness
that came with standing before the crown
melted upon meeting the person wearing
it Maggie Archibald experienced it
firsthand when she and her twin sister
were chosen to meet the queen at a
Buckingham Palace garden party last the
time she was 93 years old and she knows
she was smiling she was you know engaged
you know she was witty and when the
royal family visited Brian Bailey's
Manitoba Family Farm in 1970 they saw a
global icon who was firmly grounded you
know people think her as being Regal and
you know wearing crowns and so on here
she was just so ordinary she took
pictures went for a horseback ride and
relaxed in a lawn chair and when the
queen returned to Manitoba in 2010 she
made a beeline for Bailey's Dad when she
saw him at an event and she said Mr
Bailey what a wonderful time we had on
your farm and then Prince Philip
chippered in by saying how's the crop
Roy for all her extraordinary
accomplishments and her Peerless
longevity for many Canadians it's the
small simple things that won't soon be
forgotten microlight Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Friday from London I'm Donna Friesen
when King Charles III delivered his
first address to the nation tonight he
talked about Duty and service and his
deep love for his mother we leave you
with his final words from that speech
thanks for watching
and to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear later Papaw they want
simply to say this
thank you
thank you
for your love and devotion
to our family
and to the family of Nations you have
served so diligently all these years
May flights of Angels Sing thee to thy
rest